لتحقيق نسب مشاهدات عاليه وتحقيق ارباح
طائله صاحبه قناه على يوتيوب نشرت فيديو
موشينا لطفليها عبر الانترنت
في موقف زباله
النيابه العامه المصريه امرت بضبط واحضار
يوتيوبر تدعى ام زياد وهبه بعد تلاقيها
بلاغا من المجلس القومي للامومه والطفوله
يتضمن نشر المتهمه فيديو على قناتها على
اليوتيوب ومعها ثلاثه من اطفالها فتحدث
فيه عن اكتشافها اقامه احد طفلها علاقه
جنسيه مع شقيقته وتستنطق اثنين منهما على
الواقعه لتحقيق نسب مشاهده عاليه وتحقيق
ارباح طائله فهنا سيده بهتك العرض
والاتجار بالبشر واستغلال الاطفال لجذب
المشاهدين
ووفقا للقانون تعد هذه الواقعه اساءه
لكرامه وحقوق الطفل فما فعلته السيده الام
يعد مخالفا لقانون حظر المساسي بحقوق
الطفل في الحمايه من الاتجار به او
الاستغلال الجنسي او التجاري او الاقتصادي
له بالاضافه الى جريمه الاعتداء على مبادئ
وقيم اسريه في المجتمع المصري
[موسيقى]